a field twister making its way through
Little Rock the capital of Arkansas
ripping away roofs and walls uprooting
trees and flipping over vehicles
authorities say dozens of people are
injured some critically
a state of emergency is in place and
tens of thousands of households are
without power they're on the Lights Went
Out first and then after the lights went
out
um we all tried to get in the hallway
but the hard way not the safest place
because all our services blew out the
doors was locked but all our stuff that
was on these tables is out the window
table broke
but we all made into the bathroom it was
devastating it was uh say if you was in
an airplane and had to take a higher
altitude in your ears seems like they're
about to blow that's what it felt like
it was a lot of pressure it was quick
though it was it was less than 15 20
seconds
there were similar scenes in Iowa where
Moltres and kyota captured this video
tornadoes on
the ground the National Weather Service
was tracking at least 36 unconfirmed
tornado reports in Arkansas Tennessee
Illinois and Iowa
in the evening the storm rolled through
Illinois
the roof of the Apollo Theater in
Belvedere collapsed during a concert
tornadoes are common in the U.S
especially in the center and south of
the country but scientists say the
current storms are unusually intense
this is the first time in
I believe more than 10 years that we've
had two areas of high risk that's very
uncommon because typically
the atmosphere likes to focus on one
particular area but in this case today
we had two areas of concern and a broad
area of what's called a moderate risk
which is a four out of five on the on
the scale so this this was a pretty
widespread severe weather threat with a
large area of concern for tornado the
severe weather comes as President Joe
Biden was visiting Mississippi where at
least 26 people died after a monster
tornado battled through the state last
week
foreign